[BEEPS]
PRESENTER: In this
video, we'll be
showing you the
latest in RStudio 1.4
and how these
features can benefit
you and your team for credible,
agile, and durable data
science results.
The visual editor is one of
the more exciting new options,
making working with code in
R Markdown easier than ever.
This new interface allows you to
compose actual R Markdown using
the familiar visual interface.
With it, you have easy
access to format commands,
inserting images, tables, just
to name a few of the options
available in the visual pane.
Continuing our theme for
ease of use when authoring,
you also have the ability
to find and insert
citations from multiple
sources, including integration
with Zetero, a popular free and
open source reference manager.
This not only makes
a citation for you,
but it also creates
your bibliography,
reducing the time spent in busy
work while providing research.
Another thing we spent quite
a bit of time working on
in RStudio 1.4 is
Python, which we focused
more on in our latest releases.
The largest feature
now available
is support for Python
in the environment pane.
This allows you
to switch directly
between R mode and
Python mode in that
pane to look at data in
different environments in R
or immediately change
the view to look at data
in different modules in Python.
We can browse these
Python modules in the pane
or open it to view
directly in our workspace.
This allows you to
interact with data
in Python in much the
same way that you interact
with data in R. While
RStudio is powered by R
and will always
be an R-first IDE,
we will continue to work
to improve the ability
to use Python alongside
it, allowing teams
to mix these languages
to suit their needs.
In addition, Python
environment selections
are now available, allowing you
to select the version of Python
you would like to use or
switch between at any moment
or use in each project.
This is all powered by
the reticulate package,
which enables these Python-based
features in RStudio 1.4.
Another new feature that
many users are excited about
are rainbow
parentheses, which helps
you to more easily
view and decipher
different sections of your code.
This ultimately aids in
following deeply nested
constructs, allowing you to
view the different levels
and find the connected pairs.
In addition, you can now
use any model space font
you like to customize
your coding experience,
allowing you to tailor the
environment to your preference.
Mainly designed for
widescreen monitors,
we also provide the ability to
have multiple source columns
in the RStudio pane layout.
This allows you
to take advantage
of any space you may
have while avoiding
the opening of endless
windows on your screen.
Also new in RStudio 1.4
is the command palette,
which allows you to
invoke any RStudio
command with just a few
keystrokes, such as opening
a new R Markdown document.
This also allows you to
very easily find and learn
custom shortcuts that you
can use in your everyday work
and increase your efficiency.
One key feature that
is available in both
the open source and commercial
server version of the RStudio
IDE is the ability to
customize where your data
and configuration are stored for
both the users and the servers.
This opens up workflows
for mounting configuration
within containers, helping to
solve the long-standing problem
of users filling up
their home directories
and guiding content to where
it should appropriately go.
Moving from the open
source, let's also
walk through the
new features that
are now available with the
Pro-edition of RStudio 1.4.
Undoubtedly the most
requested and important
of our recent additions
is the ability
to authenticate RStudio
Server Pro now using SAML.
This option along with open
IDE enables single sign-on
for users and systems with
standardization that provides
fast yet reliable security.
In addition to load balancing
with a local launcher,
project sharing with a
launcher is also now available.
Previously, both
these popular features
were not available to
use at the same time.
But now, even when
you've [? launcherized ?]
an environment, you can
still share your projects
with others.
While it still requires
some setup for permissions,
these are both big features with
the commercial server version
of the RStudio IDE that
are now available to use
at the same time.
Of note for those who need
to request a GPU with SLURM,
this is now possible with
custom S batch parameters.
Another nice new feature for
the commercial server version
of the RStudio
IDE is the ability
to run Visual Studio
Code sessions.
This is currently in beta
and is great for those
who want to run longer form
Python programs while working
with other teams and projects
within the RStudio Server
environment.
[BEEPS]